récord de casos kobe 19 en alemania el
país europeo se encuentra en el peor
momento de la pandemia con cifras que
superan la segunda oleada del virus
sucedía en diciembre del año pasado
actualmente el país presenta una
incidencia semanal de 213 7 contagios
por cada 100.000 habitantes y 21 mil 932
diagnósticos se registraron en las
últimas 24 horas según los datos del
instituto robert koch de virología
la presión hospitalaria también ha
crecido pues sólo quedan 3.000 camas de
cuidados intensivos disponibles en todo
el país con un 67 por ciento de la
población vacunada algo que todavía
aleja de esta nación europea de alcanzar
la anhelada inmunidad de rebaño
el país está en un periodo de transición
entre el gobierno de angela merkel y el
venidero aún en negociación los
probables futuros miembros de la nueva
coalición alemana acordaron a finales de
octubre una nueva política sobre el
coronavirus llamada emergencia epidémica
la cual después de debatirse pasará a
votación el 18 de noviembre y estará
lista antes del 25 de ese mes según las
encuestas de percepción pública nacional
el 42% de los alemanes consideran que
las actuales medidas para hacer frente a
la pandemia son insuficientes el 27 por
ciento de las calificadas exageradas
mientras que el 31 por ciento de la
población cree que son adecuadas la
nueva política de los verdes los
socialdemócratas y el partido liberal
buscarían entre otras cosas el regreso
de los tests gratuitos que fueron
eliminados para impulsar la vacunación y
la reactivación económica